giant sand worms the guy who played
wormtongue in the lord of the rings and
whatever the hell this is david lynch
thought his 1984 version of dune was so
bad he used a fake name as the director
and with denis villeneuve's highly
anticipated reboot i thought it would be
fun to explore this wildly expensive
sci-fi flop this video will also act as
a fantastic primer for those of you who
don't know much about the dune universe
because it can get pretty confusing for
those just jumping in last but not least
make sure to hit that like and subscribe
button i plan on coming out with more
dune videos once the 2021 version hits
theaters to understand the ending it's
pivotal to get a basic hold of who the
major players are in the dune universe
this is so vital that the 1984 version
spends a whopping 10 minutes of voice
over narration giving the uninitiated a
crash course in dune politics i don't
think i've ever seen a movie spend so
much time on this and to save money this
is told entirely through paintings
instead of actually visiting these
planets and seeing the events that the
narrator describes at the time of this
writing i haven't seen villeneus version
yet and i'm curious how he'll maneuver
this problem of understanding the
world's deep lore whether he'll offer a
similar crash course introduction or
drop us right into the action making the
viewer have to put the pieces together
themselves the conflict of dune centers
around the desert planet arrakis arrakis
is the only known planet at least at
this time that contains the highly
coveted spice melange a naturally
produced awareness spectrum narcotic now
if that sounds like a mouthful let me
put it into perspective how important
this resource is imagine a drug that can
let you see into the past present and
future or one that mutates your body and
allows you to transport people through
space and time when the events of the
doom film begin the spice is controlled
by the galactic parashat empire also
known as the imperium at the head of
this empire is emperor shadom iv who
administers contracts allowing various
houses of the lands rod to extract spice
from the planet the landsrod is the body
that represents all the great houses of
the imperium among the landsrod two
powerful houses have emerged the noble
house atreides ruled by duke lado and
the malevolent house harkonnen ruled by
vladimir harkinan they rule from their
respective planets of caledon and gidi
prime so while the emperor is supposed
to maintain the peace so that the spice
can flow there are two other entities
with tremendous power that seek to
maintain stability these are the
benedescerate and the spacing guild the
spacing guild is run by the guild
navigator this weird ass creature who is
actually a human who has mutated due to
massive amounts of exposure to spice
melange the navigator can transport
these ships called highliners throughout
space in a process known as space
folding without the space guild space
travel at faster than light speeds would
not be possible so you can see how much
power these guys wield and this power
wouldn't be possible without the spice
the last important organization i want
to cover in this video is the bene
jesserit an all-female group of
quasi-religious scientific spies and
nuns who use their powers to guide
humanity along a path of insight and
stability their powers include that
appreciance the ability to see the past
present and future and if that wasn't
enough the reverend mothers the highest
rank in the bene jesuit can even untap
an ability called other memory allowing
them to access memories lost to time for
90 generations the beneficiary have
carried out a system of selective
breeding with an attempt to bring
stability to the universe they plan to
breed the daughter of duke lado atreides
with a harkonnen male which would bring
the end to the centuries-old feud
between these two houses think of it
like alliances through marriage in
medieval times but lady jessica a
benedescerate tasked with producing a
female with duke lado atreides disobeyed
her orders after falling in love with
him and instead bore him a son paul the
bender gestured have the ability to
choose the sex of their offspring and
this totally threw off the plans of the
reverend mother gaius helen moyim who
believed lady jessica's female heir
would go on to give birth to the quisats
hararak a type of prophetic figure who
would bring stability to the universe
who could also see into the future and
this is where the events of the dune
film really start lady jessica's
decision to have a male have thwarted
years of benedescerate planning and now
the benedescerate need to find a new way
to bring stability to the universe
ensuring that this spice will flow at
the beginning of dune the emperor benne
jester at space guild and harkinan all
conspire to destroy house atreides in an
attempt to bring stability the emperor
justifies his actions by telling the
guild navigator that he is fearful of
both the rising popularity of duke
atreides among the landsrod and their
development of a new weapon which
utilizes sound so the emperor along with
the harkonnen devise a sneak attack to
wipe out house atreides on arrakis and
establish hearken and dominance on the
desert planet the events that follow are
mainly told from the perspective of paul
atreides our film's protagonist and son
of duke lato it is hinted that he may be
the one spoken about in the prophecy
that kwitsat's hattarak he has dreams of
the future and when tested by the
reverend mother she exclaims no woman
child ever withstood that much if he is
indeed the one she may be able to
control him could he be the one
maybe
but will he be ours to control
upon arriving on arrakis we learn of a
group of indigenous inhabitants known as
the fremen it's actually their prophecy
that depicts this kwitsat hararak a male
the son of abena jesurite who would lead
them to freedom after house atreides is
betrayed in an attack that sees duke
lado killed paul escapes into the desert
with his mother this is where the real
test to see if he is the one begins he
teams up with a group of friend and
fighters who initially agreed to take
him in an exchange for teaching them the
weirding way advanced fighting
techniques of the benedescerate that
allows fighters teleport teleport-like
abilities mainly used in hand-to-hand
combat this was replaced in the film
version with these devices called
weirding modules they aren't in the do
novel and david lynch added them because
he didn't like the idea of quote kung fu
on sand dunes in the film but for paul
to fully transform into this prophetic
figure he must first drink from the
water of life a poisonous blue liquid
that was used by the benedictura to turn
their sisters into reverent mothers only
those with powerful control over their
mind and body can withstand the poison
and until paul any man who tried to
drink it had died paul ends up surviving
the process and it gives him enormous
powers he can see into the future and
how the emperor deceived him he'll also
have the ability to control the
sandworms and ability used in the film's
final act this gives him the title
moadib a freman word for their religious
and political leader now i personally
didn't like the end battle known as the
battle of era keen portrayed in the 1984
version where the fremen led by paul
boadib defeat the emperor and the
harkonnens part of this was that it was
terribly one-sided paul and the freeman
basically show up with a [ __ ] ton of
sand worms and weirding modules and
completely wiped the floor with their
enemies this meant there was little
tension in the film's final act an act
which should have the most but this
ending is all part of paul's
well-orchestrated plan while he's
fighting alongside the fremen he sent
his sister alia on a very important
mission alia was born prematurely on
arrakis when her mother ingested the
water of life while pregnant any normal
child would have come out like what the
benejester would call an abomination but
alia persevered with powers way beyond
normal it's never mentioned in the movie
how much time has passed since paul
joins the freeman and that final battle
but according to the book it's
approximately two years alia's powers
have her developing at an extremely
rapid pace she's even able to
communicate telepathically with paul and
get into the mind of that evil reverend
mother who advises the emperor so while
paul is fighting he orders alia to stab
the baron with a gom jabar a metacyanide
poison needle that sits upon a thimble
this is seen used by their reverend
mother in both the 84 and 2021 versions
but that death isn't where things stop
for baron vladimir harkonnen ali removes
the suspensers used to keep afloat the
baron's morbidly obese body this spins
him out of control and eventually into
the mouth of a sand worm with vladimir
defeated this leaves his nephew fade
ralpha harkonnen played by sting as the
new baron paul and fate duel each other
in an act of can-li an act which allows
disputes to be resolved without any harm
brought upon innocent bystanders fade
fights dirty biting kicking palm the
balls and utilizing hidden blades within
his suit but paul gets the upper hand
and stabs fade through the jaw and after
his death paul uses his voice without
the use of one of those weirding modules
to physically rip fade's body and the
ground underneath him in two everyone in
attendance is like yep this paul guy is
the one the prophecy foretold ma deep
had become the hand of god fulfilling
the fremen prophecy under his rule war
would become peace and hatred would
become love or so the narrator says with
paul and the freman now in control of
arrakis something magical happens rain
falls on the planet this is interesting
since early on in the movie we hear this
never one drop of rain on arrakis paul
has made it rain and the ending credits
show ocean waves in the background you
may also have noticed paul's blue eyes
much like those of the fremen these are
called eyes of a bad and are
characteristic of those exposed to high
amounts of spice now you might ask
yourself where does this leave paul and
lee freeman well that i'm going to save
for another video since those events are
depicted in subsequent novels in the
days ahead i hope to cover the 2020
version as well as the 2000 and 2003
mini series based on the other novels
children of dune so make sure to
subscribe with notifications on for that
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like the video and leave a comment with
your dune thoughts and for more bad
takes you can always find me on twitter
and instagram at pink story yt until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much